It wasn't that long ago that computers
were these strange things you
put in a separate room.
You loaded software on them from
something you got in the mail and
you printed the output on paper.
They were clearly abstract tools for
uncommon tasks.
>> Nowadays, all these devices
talk to each other and to use.
They're part of our daily lives,
and provide all sorts of value.
>From looking at movie
times to calling a taxi or
talking face to face with
a friend across the globe.
>> > And yet, much of how we interact
with computers is still abstract and
specific to the device at hand.
In fact, many people view the future
of computing as devices everywhere,
floating screens, animated graphics
on every surface, cats and
dogs living together, pandemonium.
>> But that's not what we
mean by ubiquitous computing
because it's not the device or the app
that's the most interesting thing here.
The most interesting thing is solving
real problems for real people, and
then providing that solution anywhere
and everywhere they'd want or need it.
That's what we mean by
truly ubiquitous computing.
>> When we build for
real people, technology doesn't become
more visible, it becomes less visible.
It blends into our lives and freezes
from learning obscure ways of doing
things, so that we can focus more on
what we're doing not how we're doing it.
>> We hope you've fun learning
the design principles and
building blocks for these new form
factors as we've had teaching them.
>> Now, go out and make the world
an even cooler place to live in.